And everybody welcome to another holistic health and healing call. This is episode 10 of our course calls and we want to jump right into the few questions that we have.
Well, what are autoimmune diseases curable? Our autoimmune disease is curable. Well, the honest answer to that is no, they're not.
I mean, I believe God can do anything, but reality, you know, some things just are not going to go away. There is no current drug, you know, medicine, nutritional, functional medicine.
The formula for making, you know, self antibodies disappear in a person's body. So an autoimmune disease is when a person has antibodies to self tissue.
And then there's three different phases or stages of autoimmune disease.
One of the third stage is when the person has, you know, the auto antibodies, we had self antibodies and now they have tissue damage.
So let's say in the case of like rheumatoid arthritis, they'd have bolognodules on their joints. They might have swan like deformity of their joints, meaning their fingers are, are deformied outward.
And this is not something you could be sure. So the treatment from a functional medicine perspective is to manage it, you know, the treatment from a standard medicine perspective is to manage it as well, but they're managing it through drugs.
The functional medicine perspective is trying to manage it through natural needs problem with managing some of these diseases through drugs, the drugs that bring nasty and have a lot of side effects and cause other problems. And a lot of people just don't like to continue to take them.
So managing them through natural needs can help reduce symptoms can help get at the cause, but it's still not even if you let's say the cause of your autoimmune disease was biotox or let's say the cause of rheumatoid if we keep to that example, very common cause of rheumatoid is heavy metal toxicity.
But even if they get rid of the heavy metals, you're not, you haven't gotten rid of the rheumatoid factor. You haven't got rid of the antibodies to the joint capsules and you haven't got rid of the continued destruction. So you can help a person, it could decrease symptoms, it could decrease the flares.
And that's really the goal in a functional medicine perspective is to manage them more appropriately so you don't, you know, you could make choices about your drug use and maybe decrease the side effects of those and you can decrease your layers and your symptoms.
Second question if live gets into my brain, how do I know and what's the best solution? Well, live and its coal infections can and may cross the blood brain barrier.
And if they do cross the blood brain barrier immediately your immune system in your brain kicks in, which is your microglial cells to try to kill them and eliminate the infection.
The problem is that by that it's coal infections can damage these microglial cells and then you can end up worst case scenario, second worst case scenario is you end up with what's called microglial priming. I have a whole video on that called brain inflammation.
But microglial priming causes a huge inflammation process in the brain and causes continual problems for literally decades. It's not something we've posted away. Let's
microglial cells are damaged in this prime state. They don't undamaged and go out into the prime state and your goal is to try to keep them in a nodded flammatory prime state. And I give examples of how to do that. We work through that as an individual basis.
Second, the number one worst case scenario is you also, you can develop antibodies to brain tissue and you would develop antibodies to brain tissue. Now you have basically another autoimmune disease that's affecting neural tissue and that could cause constant erosion of degeneration and degrading of neural tissue and all sorts of problems.
So it does become a nasty thing. This is something that's there's no easy solution to this.
You do want to work on building back that blood brain barrier, but you have to work on decreasing the inflammation decreasing the prim microglials and trying to push them into the nodded flammatory state.
And it's a giant process and it's a work in progress too, because it's not something that just happens very quickly. So again, it's managing. So this person now has a lot of immune issue with your managing this disease, trying to decrease layers.
Next question. What's the best way to test for food sensitivities? There's a lot of different food sensitivity tests out there. Some are less expensive, but they're not nearly as good a quality. The best quality test is the Syrex test.
And the most appropriate Syrex test are the most expanded Syrex test is the Syrex array 10 for food sensitivities, the array 10.
I have information on the courses on why it's the best test. There's numerous reasons why it's the antibody that it tests, it's tested for cooked raw foods.
And you have different peptides in the cooked versus raw food. So you have to test for both of them.
And it gives you a good balanced number of foods that most people eat. So that is the best test to do with Syrex array care.
That's it for questions for today. Hope this blessed everybody. And I'll be praying for you and I'll talk to you in a couple of weeks. Bye bye.